[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنينه نياهو الى
وجوب العمل على اجتفاف فكره اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وقطع الطريق امامها وقال ان
اسرائيل تريد بقاء السلطه الفلسطينيه وعلى
استعداد لدعمها وقد اعتبرت رئاسه
الفلسطينيه تصريحه
دليلا على حقيقه النوايا الاسرائيليه
الرافضه للشرعيه والقانون الدوليين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات
ما الرسائل التي ارادني تنياهو توجيهها
بهذه التصريحات الان والى من والى اي مدى
تعكس هذه التصريحات حقيقه السياسه
الاسرائيليه فيما يخص اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه تجاه ما
كشفه نتنياهو بخصوص الموقف من دوله
فلسطينيه وبخصوص نظره تل ابيب تجاه السلطه
ودورها والموقف منها وكيف سيتعامل او كيف
ستستقبل واشنطن راعيه عمليه السلام في
المنطقه دعوه اسرائيل لاشتتاف فكره اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه وما موقفها من مشروع حل
الدولتين بعد تصريحات
[موسيقى]
بحسب ما نقلته اذاعه اسرائيليه رسميه فان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
حسم صراحه ما اكدته ضمنا كل سياسات حكومته
وحكومات اسرائيليه سابقه
ادعى الى وجوب العمل على اشتفاف فكره
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه وقطع الطريق على
تطلعات الفلسطينيين لاقامه دوله مستقله
يتنياهو يتحدث وفقا للقناه في جلسه مغلقه
للجنه الخارجيه والامن التابعه للكنيست
قال ايضا ان اسرائيل تستعد لفتره ما بعد
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
وانها تريد بقاء السلطه الفلسطينيه وانها
تستفيد من وجودها وان تل ابيب لن تسمح
بانهيار السلطه الفلسطينيه وانها على
استعداد لدعمها ماليا
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا في
بدايه هذه الحلقه من القدس الونافيتار
المستشار السابق للشؤون العربيه في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه على ان ينضم الينا
لاحقا فيما بعد الاستاذ نواف العامر
والدكتور ريتشارد ستايل من واشنطن ابدا
ما الرسائل التي اراد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو ارسالها ولمن
السؤال ممتاز لازم نكون بكل الصراحه انه
ما يتعودنا
لعيلنات سياسيه بالموضوع الفلسطيني من
رئيس الحكومه الانترنياهو ما بيسوي
تصريحات او اعلانات بهذه الموضوع بشكل
اسبوعي او شهرين
هذا مش عادي
الهدف من ناحيه نتنياهو في هذا الوقت
السياسيه اقبال السلطه الفلسطينيه وتحت
الرئيس محمود عباس
اذني العنوان او الهدف من ناحيته هو
الامريكان البيت الابيض
تحت رئيس جو بايدن اول رئيس الجاي بعده
والعنوان الثاني هو مش بس الامكان بس كمان
السلطه الفلسطينيه
للشرق الاسرائيلي هو مش عنصر المهم في هذه
الموضوع في هذه الوعب
حتى نتنياهو الهدف المركزي وراء هذا
الاعلان هو
وصول الى
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض هو الهدف كمان الشرق الاوسط
الامارات
والدول الخليج وسعوديه فقط
سياسه
بالنسبه
لموضوع فلسطين او القضيه الفلسطينيه اليوم
من زمان هي وصول الى
استقلال
الحكومه الفلسطينيه بس مش وصول الى دوله
فلسطينيه هذا مش جديده
اخر خطاب طبعا نتنياهو بالنسبه
الفلسطينيه كان قبل 15 سنه معناته نحن
موجودين في الظروف مختلفه جدا وبموضوع
دولتين حسب السياسه والفكره الامريكيه
اذني
كمان الامريكان بيعرفوا انه هذه الفكره هي
مش واقعه
بالظروف الغينه ما في اي امكانيه
لو مرينا للعنوان الثاني سريعا السلطه
الفلسطينيه هذا لا يضعف السلطه
ونتنياهو كما قال يريد ان تبقى هذه السلطه
ومستعد لدعمها وانه حريص على انهيارها هذا
لا يكشف دور السلطه كدور وظيفي يخدم
اسرائيل اكثر مما يخدم الفلسطينيين
انا
طبعا قياده هو حريص على نعم
ما في اي قياده
في يدي جدي او كي يدي معروف في القياده
الفلسطينيه انه بفكر بشكل
عقلي انه فكره الدولتين هي فكره واقعه
اذني هذا الفكره موجوده او متبعه للسابق
يعني ومش لليوم انا ما بعرف ولا واحد انه
هذه الفكره هي ملموسه عشان هيك اذن
الرساله الوحيده المهمه من ناحيه نتنياهو
هي هي مسج او الرساله لقياده الفلسطينيه
الجايه كمان بعد
[موسيقى]
من ناحيته
انسانيه
بمختلف من
التصريحات تبع اليمين المتطرف داخل اعتلاف
انه ما في اي نيه او اي مسلحه للانهيار
كمان انهيار نسبي من ناحيته الفلسطينيه
موجوده في غملا ولازم تبكي هناك بدون اي
تغيير جوده طيب العنوان الثالث قبل قليل
قلت انه الدول الشرق الاوسط ودول الخليج
العربي وذكرت بعض الدول ماذا يريد ان يقول
لهم يعني
اطبعوا معي ولكن بدون مقابل بدون دوله
فلسطينيه
اظني رئيس نتنياهو بيعرف في التكتيكات في
السياسيه قبال الدول الخليج والسعوديه
كمان حسستان من ناحيته الهدف المركزي
الهدف السياسي المركزيه في المستقبل
القريب هو تكادم جدي بالنسبه لمفاوضات
وكمان لازم لازم ناخذ بعين الاعتبار انه
كمان ما في اي دليل او زعيم عربي انه بفكر
انه دوله فلسطينيه هي امكانيه ملموسه من
ناحيه الواقع
دوله مستقله بحدود 67 وهو الى اخره اديني
المسج او الغساله طبعا قبل الخليج
والسعوديه انه في امكانيه
واقتصادي واجتماعي بالنسبه
للوضع السياسي او الواد العام تبع اسيوط
والمجتمع الفلسطيني كله في ظفر الربيع بس
موضوع الدوله او موضوع الدوله المستقله او
هذه الفكره ممكن بتكون
الوسائل الاعلام بس في حكي السياسي بس مش
اكثر من هيك اظن نتنياه وتفكر ابل فقر
بشكل جيد قبل
مجانيا مع الدول نعم اكيد اخذ كل
كل التاثير اللي ممكن يكون بعض العيلات
طيب شكرا لك انت مستشار سابق للشؤون
العربيه في وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
ومستشار سابق لمنسق اعمال الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شكرا
لك وطبعا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ردت على
تصريحات نتنياهو بشان ضروره العمل على
اجتثاث فكره اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
بتاكيدها ان قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
عاصمتها القدس الشرقيه هي الحل الوحيد
لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار الرد الذي جاء
على لسان الناطق باسم الرئاسه نبيله
بردانه اضاف ان تصريحاتي نيتانياهو تظهر
للعالم حقيقه النوايا الاسرائيليه الرافضه
للشرعيه الدوليه وللقانون الدولي وانه لا
يوجد شريك اسرائيلي يريد تحقيق السلام
القائم على الشرعيه الدوليه
ونرحب الان بضيفينا من نابلس الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي نواف العامر ومن نيوجيرسي
الدكتور ريتشارد جولد ستايل المستشار
السابق في اداره الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
بالكلينسون اهلا بكما واردما كان
العامر استمعت الى ما قاله الونا فيتار
هذه التصريحات تصريحات تيتانياهو موجهه
الى عناوين مختلفه لنقف عند العنوان
المتعلق بالسلطه الفلسطينيه هل تفهم
السلطه الفلسطينيه هذا الكلام او كيف يمكن
ان تستقبله
اسعد الله اوقاتكم جميعا في الحقيقه يعني
ان الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه لم
تتوقف لحظه ولم تتوانى عن ايصال الرسائل
السياسيه تجاه الفلسطينيين سواء كانوا
رسميين في السلطه والمنظمه او القوى
المعارضه او يعني اتعارف عليه بقوه
المقاومه
نتنياهو يرسل الرسائل ولا يعني لا يخفي
وجهه خلف قناعات عديده كما يفعل مع
الاسرائيليين هو واضح يعني عندما تحدث في
تهنئته لترامب عندما فاز بالانتخابات
الامريكيه تحدث معه ثم عاد الى الكنيست
وعندما رجع وعندما تم انتقاده قال انا لا
اتحدث عن دوله فلسطينيه انما اتحدث عن
دوله ناقصه يعني منزوعه الصلاحيات منزوعه
الدسم السياسي والامني والعسكري السلطه
الفلسطينيه تعلم علم اليقين حقيقه الاهداف
والنوايا الاسرائيليه التي ارسلها نتنياهو
واعتقد ان اهم الاهداف هو
سنعود الى ثوره اصلاح هذا الخلل اذهب الى
واشنطن ودكتور جاين امريكا هل تشعر
بالواشنطن هل تشعر بالحرج من هذه
التصريحات وهي التي طالما سوقت وطالما
راعت وطالما بعت باعت فكره الحل الدولتين
للعرب وللفلسطينيين
لقد قرات ولقد استمعت ايضا الى التعليقات
التي ادلى بها رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
ويمكنني ان اقول انني اعتقد ان معناها هو
ان الفلسطينيين لا يمكنهم ان يعلنوا عن
هذه الدوله بشكل احادي بل يجب ان ياتي
الحل بشكل تفاوضي لانه اذا ما ابتعد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء عن فكره حل الدولتين هو يلعب
لعبه خطيره مرتكزه ادورني على المقاطعه
انت من اين جئت بهذا الكلام كيف فهمت
تصريحات نتنياهو بهذه الطريقه وهو قال
بالحرف الواحد
اجتثاث فكره الدوله الفلسطينيه كيف
ترجمتها الى هذا الكلام الذي تقوله الان
مجددا سوف نعرف لاحقا لانه يبدو لي انه
يتعين على رئيس مجلس الوزراء ان يوضح اذا
ما عنا ان فكره حل الدولتين هي وراء
الجميع هذه فكره او معارضه رادكاليه واذا
ما عنا ذلك
ربما يقول هذه الفكره او يعبر عنها بشكل
اوضح مما قاله اليوم
انت تنت
ظر هو اكبر وقال الكلام وانت تنتظر ان
يشرح هذا الكلام طيب قبل قليل كان الضيف
الاسرائيلي الون افيتار فهم الكلام كما
فهمه جميعا وهو في اسرائيل وهو اسرائيل
وقال كان يقصد او تحدث عن المقصد الذي
قصده نتنياهو هو اجتثاث فكره الدوله
الفلسطينيه
انت على حق نعم
نتنياهو على مر السنوات بالاضافه الى عدد
كبير من المستشارين من اليمين واقصى
اليمين يعتقدون انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك
دوله فلسطينيه وقد قالوا ذلك من قبل ولكن
ما من الرئيس مجلس وزراء اسرائيلي قال قبل
اليوم انه
ليس هناك حل دولتين لذلك هذا هو السبب
الوحيد الذي يدفعني الى التفكير بانه
لربما معناه
نتنياهو ليس بالحده التي تشير اليها
التقارير وسوف نكتشف لاحقا لانه اذا معنا
ذلك هذه لعبه خطيره ليس فقط
نعم نعم قبل قليل انت قلت هو يتحدث لتتحدث
يعني وهو لا يخفي وجهه هل تتحدث السلطه او
هل تنظر الى نفسها في المراه وتنظر الى
هذا الوجه وتدرك ما يقوله نتنياهو
حتى يعني ربما هذه التصريحات تفضح السلطه
عندما يقول نحن حريصون على عدم انهيار
السلطه الفلسطينيه وسندعمها مليا وحرصون
على بقائها كيف تفهم هذا الكلام
افهم الموضوع يعني كما يفهمه سياسيين
والنخب والمثقفين وكما يفهمه الساسه في
صنع صانع القرار في تل ابيب وصانع القرار
في المطبخ السياسي لدى الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
التينياو عندما يتحدث عن هذا الموضوع يعني
هو يفرق ويميز ويفصل بين السلطه وبين
الكيان الفلسطيني كدوله لانه حسب
الاتفاقيات الموقعه في اوسلو وفي غيرها من
الملاحق في كام ديفيد وغيرهم يتحدثوا عن
سلطه فلسطينيه بحكم ذاتي محدود منزوع
السلاح تم تاجيل القضايا الرئيسيه
والثوابت والقضايا الحساسه والهامه الى
مراحل انتهت يعني على السلطه ان تفهم
وتدرك ان مده اتفاقيه اوسلو انتهت لماذا
التمسك بالجيفه السياسيه لماذا التمسك
بالنطيحه والمترديه والموقوده الا ما اكل
السبع بينما الاسرائيلي يلفظ
ويعلن اكثر مره ان اوسلو انتهت وانه كما
قال نتنياهو يعني قبل يومين او في الساعات
الاخيره اننا نتمسك
باتفاقياتنا مع السلطه التي تقدم يعني
تنجح في قضايا انما تقدم لنا خدمات يعني
هنا مهم جدا مطلوب من السياسيين في السلطه
وصانع القرار ان يجيبوا وان يردوا على
نتنياهو الذي يقول ان اي نجاح للسلطه في
الساحه الفلسطينيه انما هم يقدمون خدمات
لنا وبالتالي عندما يتحدث بكل هذه البجاحه
وكل هذه الوقاحه السياسيه هو لا يتحدث من
فراغ لانه اصلا منذ اللحظات الاولى قبل
العام سته وتسعين يتحدث عن رفض اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه في 96 وكان احدى اسباب نجاحاته
عندما قام الجناح العسكري الحماس في شهرين
فبراير ومارس برد عملياتها على ردا على
اغتيال يحيى عياش وسقط شمعون بيرس وفاز
نتنياهو حتى نت له في العام الفين وتسعه
تحدث يعني بشكل او باخر عن حل الدولتين
لكنه عاد
يعني عاده انتكس وتراجع وتنصل من هذه
الدعوه في انتخاب في الدعايه الانتخابيه
للعام 2015 وسبق انقال لترامب في اتصاله
واراد ان يوضح للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
والناقدين في الكنيست وفي حزب الكود انه
يتحدث عن دوله فلسطينيه ناقزه ناقصه
الدوله يعني بمعنى انها منزوعه الدسم لا
تملك المعابر لا تملك السلاح لا تملك حق
التجاره والاستيراد والعقامه العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع الدول كامله العضويه الكل
الفلسطيني يدرك حقيقه تصريحات نتنياهو
الاهداف الرئيسيه التي ذهب اليها اهم هدف
هو يعني هو الغايات التي قامت من اجلها
دوله الكيان الهدف الرئيسي والتكات عليه
هو الاباده والتطهير العرقي والاهم من ذلك
الفكر الصهيوني ولا زالت الحكومات متعاقبه
تتمسك بهذا الفكر هو انكار الاخر وقد تحدث
قبل شهور في باريس العاصمه الفرنسيه وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي عندما قال انه لا وجود
لشعب فلسطين على هذه الارض هذه الحكومات
وهذه وهذه الافكار المتطرفه التي تلغي
الاخر انما تستمد ليس فقط من افكار سياسيه
وانما من عقائد ايديولوجيه تلغي الاخر
وتعتبر ان الاخر
الذين خلقوا لاجل خدمه الاسرائيلي اعود
الى دكتور الان المشكله انه ليس هناك شريك
اسرائيلي هكذا تقول الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لم يعد هناك اذا شريك
اسرائيلي ما العمل كيف تنفذ فكره الدولتين
التي رعتها واشنطن
في الحقيقه
هذا السؤال الصعب المطروح منذ سنوات طويله
بكل تاكيد قبل رئاسه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبكل صراحه نتحدث بصراحه فكره
ان بنيامين نتنياهو وحلفاء بنيامين
نتنياهو المتطرفين في حكومته طالما كانوا
في السلطه هذه الفكره فكره حل الدوله
ليست
بالمنال وبالتالي يجب ان اتذكر ذلك ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لن تتخلى عن
هذه الفكره والشركاء في منطقه الخليج
يصرون على هذه الفكره واعتقد ان بنيامين
نتنياهو يفهم انه لمصلحه اسرائيل
الاقتصاديه لمصلحه مستقبل اسرائيل لا
يمكنها ان تقطع هذه الصله التي تبنيها من
خلال اتفاقيات ابرهه المبنيه بشكل اساسي
على ركن اساسي الا وهو حل الدولتين يتعين
علينا ان نرى مع الوقت نعم نتنياهو لم يكن
دائما لحل الدولتين بما انك دكتور بما انك
اشرت الى دول التطبيع يعني اليوم خرجوا
وقال على عينك يا تاجر انا اطبع معي بدون
اي مقابل تطبيع مجاني وهذا ما شرحه قبل
قليل المحلل الاسرائيلي
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يقطع الطريق على مسار
التطبيق عفوا بالنسبه لي اسرائيل هذا
الكلام الذي يقوله هذه التصريحات
اذا ما كانت التقارير الصحفيه دقيقه يبدو
بكل تاكيد ان التطبيع مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هو قيد النقاش ومن بين الشروط
بالنسبه الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه هو
التغيير في المقاربه تجاهها الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من قبل اسرائيل مجددا اقول سوف
نكتشف مع الوقت ما اذا كان بنيامين
نتنياهو يعني ذلك ولكن هذا ما يقوله شكرا
لك دكتور ريتشارد جود ستايل مستشار سابق
في اداره الرئيس بيل كلينتون شكرا لك
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا الكاتب والمحلل الصحفي
الفلسطيني نواف العامر من رام الله شكرا
لكم الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
مهورال الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]